bonjour à toutes les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin avec nous sur
rt france alors les sages femmes on l'a
vu de nouveau en grève ce week end et
mouvement de grève inédit également dans
des enseignes qui ne connaissent
généralement pas de mouvements sociaux
ça s'est passé ces dernières semaines
ils réclament tous des hausses de
salaires voyez à quoi c'est dû l'analyse
de mathieu plane pour commencer il est
directeur adjoint du département analyse
et prévision de l'ofce au regard de
l'inflation je vous directement sur le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages des salariés
les plus modestes et ceux de la classe
moyenne il y a donc des revendications
salariales pour compenser cette hausse
de l'inflation
sauf que la position de négociation a
changé avec la crise beaucoup
d'entreprises ont du mal à trouver de la
main d'oeuvre qualifiée cela crée un
nouveau rapport de force les salariés
sont dans une position plus favorable
pour exiger des hausses de salaires ils
ont peut-être moins peur de perdre leur
travail dans ces conditions là alors on
le voit la question des bas salaires
touchent à peu près toutes les
professions c'est une priorité on le
voit bien aussi avec les candidats en
campagne un contexte d'inflation forte
mais aussi pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
favorable à une une marge de manoeuvre
pour négocier selon vous elle la porte
ou pas
oui bien sûr alors il ya deux points
distinguer tout d'abord il faut pouvoir
redonner de l'argent et du soupe aux
français chaque mois dans la proposition
marine le pen et diffère propositions
qu'elle présente jusqu'à présent on doit
pouvoir donner entre 5,50 euros et de
100 euros rendu aux salariés chaque mois
mais en contre partie également il faut
pouvoir que les entreprises puissent
pouvoir augmenter les salaires et pour
ceux ci nous avons plusieurs mesures
notamment avec une baisse des
cotisations patronales et ceux de 2020
ce dès 2022 et pendant cinq ans avec une
exonération sur les salaires qui serait
à hauteur du smic et jusqu'à trois fois
de ceux qui gagnent le smic ça c'est ce
que propose marine exonérations pour les
patrons et ça veut dire que la sécurité
sociale dans la finance comme un
exode voulez vous voulez soi-disant
donné dès demain vous le prenez de
l'autre ça va être pris par les sur les
impôts ça va être pris surtout sur un
recul des services publics s'est déjà on
le voit dans l'hôpital les problèmes
quillard par manque de budget manque de
financement et vous voulez diminuer
encore ça non madame non madame il ya
énormément d'économies à faire mais il
faut également préserver la
compétitivité des entreprises si on
regarde le salaire médian en france par
rapport au reste de l'europe au niveau
de salaire et d'ailleurs on va le
montrer on va montrer ce salaire
justement au niveau européen où la
france se situe 20e d'ailleurs
exactement dans le monde alizée je vous
en pris part dont je vous ai coupé la
parole a par ailleurs dans le monde il
ya eu marre c'était pour augmenter sa
c'est ellen la porte qui vous répondais
madame monique simard
le salaire net médian en france il est
de 1940 euros si on regarde par rapport
au niveau de l'union européenne et par
rapport au taux horaire de l'union
européenne la france on est à 15 euros
20 le danemark qui sont à 27 euros on
est loin derrière l'allemagne on est
loin derrière les pays scandinaves
on est très mal placé alors à faire des
économies en a plein à faire je vous
parle en tant que député européen chaque
année on perd environ 10 milliards entre
ce que vers celui la france et l'union
européenne est ce que l'union européenne
nous redonne donc des économies pour ne
pas que ça pèse en effet sur le social
il y en a à faire dans diverses
organique dabbagh surtout les
entreprises 2 oui on entend bien
quelles sont vos solutions à vous on
entend de plus en plus de témoignages
d'employés qui ont des emplois où il
arrivait finalement à vivre correctement
jusqu'à présent ce n'est plus le cas de
plus en plus de l'employé nous disent
vouloir prendre d'aider des petits
boulots à côté pour finir les fins de
mois quel quelles sont vos solutions
les solutions ils sont très simples les
entreprises du cac 40 et 60 milliards de
bénéfices rien pour les six premiers
mois de
et s'il ya de l'argent à prendre c'est
là qu'il faut prendre effectivement les
salaires ils sauront ils sont trop bas
aujourd'hui c'est avec l'inflation c'est
impossible de s'en sortir avec un smic
avec même 1500 milles
castex lui-même a donné des données une
prime ridicule de 100 euros pour les
salaires inférieurs à 2000 euros ça veut
dire que lui même il décide en dessous
de 2000 euros on peut pas s'en sortir
donc ces deux augmentation très forte de
300 400 500 euros qu'il faut par mois
mais pas seulement c'est pour que ça
soit pas encore pris par l'inflation il
faut absolument que les salaires que la
hausse des salaires soient indexés sur
l'inflation si les prix augmentent les
salaires ils doivent augmenter il va
augmenter aussi mais en fonction des
prix réellement que l'on paye parce que
c'est l'insee annonce toujours des démos
des taux d'inflation qui ne
correspondent pas c'est la honte quand
on regarde l'insee annonce quand même
degré que 50 % d'augmentation ce manga
27% sur sur le gazole va être faire un
plein d'essence pour des gens qui vont
travailler ses 25 à 30 euros de plus par
semaine c'est ces prix là qu'il faut
qu'il faut prendre en compte pour
augmenter les salaires est ce que la
france est un pays de bas salaires le
pays on l'a vu est classée 20e en termes
de revenu par tête selon la banque
mondiale en tout cas c'est ce que pense
le patron de la cgt philippe martinez
regarder
même si le smic a augmenté très peu au
1er octobre il faut une loi qui impose
aux branches d'augmenter automatiquement
les minima quand le smic augmente dans
le commerce tous les minima de branche
sont en dessous du smic
réaction hélène la porte augmenter le
smic finalement c'est bien mais il faut
aussi augmenter les minima dans le même
temps sinon ça n'a pas de sens qu'en
pensez vous
expliquer la coupe et augmenter votre
deuxième au deuxième paquet minergie gmt
accusant les augmenter les salaires bas
dans les entreprises en même temps que
l'on augmente le smic sinon on a des
salaires de personnes qui travaillent
qui sont inférieurs au smic
oui je dit en substance philippe maire
oui j'aime me
pendre à madame pas tout faire
reese madame parle il faut pouvoir
préserver aussi la compétitivité
notamment des pme c'est pour ça que la
mesure de marine le pen en exonérant les
cotisations patronales des personnes qui
gagnent le smic et jusqu'à 3 fois le
smic ça permet de redonner du souffle
aux salariés
on vous entendez quelqu'un qui gagne
24000 euros brut
vous m'entendez mal ça y est balisé je
vous en prie ça transcende et mieux
lanfains gc je vous en prie je vous en
prie aller saluer par nos excuses
il va gagner 24000 euros bruts annuels
l'entreprise elle va payer 2100 euros de
cotisations patronales supplémentaires
par an si on augmente de 10% quelqu'un
qui est un salarié
malheureusement on a vraiment un
problème de le deal c'est en fait la
seule entreprise
on va l'entreprise sera exonérée de
cotisations patronales
alors la rencontre malheureusement c'est
trop c'est trop haché hélène la porte on
a du mal à suivre votre raisonnement
restez avec nous on va vous rappeler on
va en parler avec avec monique d'abba
que pensez-vous de du fait de faire
peser la charge sur les entreprises ce
que ce que réfute justement hélène la
porte vous vous faites finalement peser
la charge sur l'état
non pas sur l'état sur sur les grandes
entreprises du cac 40 sur les sur les
actionnaires sur les plus riches dans ce
pays qui font leur fortune sur sur le
travail de chacun et c'est sûr sur cet
argent là qu'il faut prendre et là y'a
de quoi faire parce que sur les
entreprises pas assez compétitive depuis
comment depuis des années au roof est ce
ce cinéma là alors qu'en réalité la
france est un des pays où le travail est
le plus rapportent le plus c'est l'axé
c'est les meilleurs résultats de en
compétitivité donc faut arrêter avec ce
cirque là c'est il faut prendre l'argent
là où il est là où il est c'est dans les
caisses des actionnaires du grand
patronat c'est les milliards avec
lesquels il jongle encore d'années et
est argent là où que de l'investir
justement là où il y en a besoin dans
les services publics dans tout ce qui
aide à la population
c'est bah il sert à spéculer et à
préparer les prochaines crises
économiques ou d'un coup tout s'effondre
c'est ça le problème donc c'est là qu'il
faut aller chercher l'argent mais ça le
rassemblement national ne veut pas le
faire c'est eux c'est vraiment s'en
prendre aux plus pauvres pour pouvoir
préserver les plus riches c'est ben non
le rassemblement national ce serait
davantage ce que vous voudrez faire la
droite et encore avec quelques nuances
on va on va passer au crible ailleurs
les propositions des candidats
revaloriser les petits salaires ça fait
consensus chez les candidats à gauche et
pour y parvenir à gauche ce serait
plutôt via une hausse du smic qui
veulent tous l'augmenter de 10% et le
pcf lui est bien plus généreux regardez
la première mesure que nous proposons
pour la france c'est d'augmenter le smic
de 20% le smic actuellement
2258 euros nets 1589 euros brut serait
ainsi porté à 1500 euros nets 1800 euros
bruts par votre réaction à monique
d'havas sachant pour les finances et
fabien roussel propose un impôt coville
et le triplement de l' isf qu'en pensez
vous
c'est le triplement de la sf faudrait
déjà la remettre en place c'est parce
qu'elle a quand même été supprimés
c'est est bon à l'impôt vide mais qui le
paye c'est
les entreprises qui feraient des
bénéfices sur les vaccins notamment
justement grâce à la crise
robert sawi c'est prendre sur les
bénéfices pour et sur les milliards
accumulés pour augmenter les les profils
pour augmenter pendant les salaires oui
c'est là qu'il faut aller le chercher
maintenant est-ce que le pc on aura
vraiment la volonté politique si si il
est au gouvernement on verra bien mais
parce que quand il ya vu avec le ps
c'est sais quoi dans ce sens là qu'il
est allé alors je pense qu on vous
entend mieux hélène la porte bienvenue à
nouveau sur notre plateau mind on vous
l'avait dit un propose une exonération
des charges patronales pour les
entreprises qui augmentent de 10% tous
les salaires jusqu'à 3 smic pour elle il
est temps que le travail paie jordan
bardella a précisé aussi son programme
en rien
marine le pen veut exonérer d'impôt sur
le revenu tous les jeunes jusqu'à 30 ans
alors exonérer exonérer d'impôt le sur
le revenu tous les jeunes de moins de 30
ans la peau la proposition a fait pas
mal réagir est-ce que c'est réalisable
comment selon vous oui bien sûr séraline
alors je voulais pardonnez moi tout à
l'heure ça faisait jouer comme ça on
peut sur la part d'exonération des
cotisations patronales en fait je
voulais vous donner un exemple concret
puisque ça permet en fait aux français
de pouvoir s'imaginer comment ça se
passerait un salarié qui gagne 24000
euros bruts annuels en faisant cette
l'entreprise doit payer de 1100 euros de
cotisations patronales si on augmente
salariés au semi de 10% elle doit
l'entreprise devrait payer 1600 euros de
cotisations patronales supplémentaires
le deal quel est il c'est à dire que
cette entreprise sera exonérée de ses
cotisations patronales mais en
contrepartie elle devra redonner du
pouvoir d'achat à ce salarié donc ça
permet en fait tous les mois de
récupérer quasiment 140 euros
non notre corps comment ces flics qui
fait l'état mais il y avait mêlée thomis
à l'état de faire quand même une idée
des économies il ya des énormément
d'économies à faire et ça madame la bad
pour alourdir également il ya beaucoup
ya beaucoup de choses à faire dans tous
les domaines je vous ai donné tout à
l'heure l'exemple de l'union européenne
chaque année anvers entre 26 et 27
milliards d'euros à l'union européenne
on en perd deux environ 10 milliards ça
c'est un premier exemple des coûts louer
elle a plein d'autres au niveau de la
gestion de l'état des économies en
affaires partout donc madame ne pas que
moi j'étais des têtes des entreprises du
cac40 pas d'âme mais il ya toutes les
pme auxquelles il faut penser qui est
notre tissu notre violence exercée sur
scène quand de l'argent qu'il faut
prendre c'est sûr les actionnaires c'est
nous on parle pas de faire payer les
petites entreprises et encore moi un
boulanger du coin et mai font leur faire
payer l'état c'est c'est de toute façon
abandonné reprendre d'une main ce qu'on
a donné de l'autre c'est parce que
l'état quand il fait des économies c'est
sur les services publics qui le fait
donc c'est c'est sur les services aux
plus pauvres c'est là dessus et s'il ya
du porc qui payent chaque sapeur ont
fait à vous faire des discours la
mission les temps il ya la fraude
sociale la fraude fiscale le coup
également d'immigration c'est quelque
chose aussi dont il faut parler madame
ya énormément défaut chaque fois qu'il
ya les études là dessus l'émigration
l'immigration elle rapporte elle ne
coûte pas ça c'est faux c'est toujours
entièrement faux il ya eu des tas de
l'étude là dessus et à chaque fois elle
démontre le contraire de ce que vous
dites dansez vous mais vous voulez
absolument épargné les entreprises il
faut surtout pas que ça coûte aux
entreprises il faut surtout pas qu'elle
prenne assurent leur repli pascale roze
montrer le responsable vis-à-vis d'elle
si vous venez au lavoir il faut relancer
le pouvoir d'achat il faut relancer
également l'économie regardez le salaire
médian en france par rapport aux autres
pays de l'union européenne on à 1940
euros et ne vienne dont
[Musique]
les profits sont tous repartis à la
hausse s'est il n'y a pas besoin de
relancer l'économie allait relancer déjà
ils n'ont pas arrêté de 2 à longueur de
pages de journaux
quel point tout à quel point c'est tout
et est reparti c'est pas vrai l'argent
il existe il faut
réponse je n'existe pas titi points
niveau de l'europe c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure quand j'ai un
problème technique nous sommes au niveau
du salaire médian en taux horaire à 15
euros vin on est loin derrière les
scandinaves l'allemagne le danemark est
en premier à plus de 27 euros il ya
énormément oui oui non hausse des
salaires ne peut pas tout faire peser
sur les entreprises je ne suis désolé
l'état doit aussi se dire qu'il y aura
moins de recettes et faire des économies
parce qu'il ya énormément de points sur
lesquels l'état doit faire des économies
alors pour répondre à votre question
pour une mesure concrète dès le départ
marine le pen dès l'instant où elle sera
président de la république la tva
passera à 5 5% pour tous les produits de
première nécessité comme le gaz le fioul
carburant au lieu des 20 % actuels parce
que ce sont des dépenses qui sont
incompressibles ça pour les français
vous parliez en effet de l'essence qui
pèsent sur les ménages donc ça ça permet
de redonner 12 milliards d'euros aux
français alors on dernière question il
nous reste peu de temps plein les yeux
monique d'abba comprend bien que
l'exemple de total total ses 4,6
milliards de bouteilles sur le troisième
trimestre cette année en même temps que
pour les pour les travailleurs qui
utilisent leur voiture c'est dans les 35
euros de plus par par semaine pour faire
le plein quand c'est qu'on impose à
total de prendre sur ces milliards pour
baisser le prix du carburant quand c'est
qu'on en mangerait comme personne dire
ça pour pour pourquoi jamais allé
chercher là où vraiment il ya l'argent
alors que c'est c'est les
travailleurs/ses les plus pauvres qui
est qui en souffrent le plus on a bien
compris en tout cas que cette question
était prioritaire l'europe d'ailleurs
sont saisi l'union européenne dans
l'union européenne 21 pays sur 27
dispose d'un salaire minimum le
parlement l'une vient de donner son
accord pour entamer des négociations
pour une directive visant à garantir à
tous est-ce que c'est faisable selon
vous hélène l'apport très court non
c'est pas faisable déjà dans la mesure
où vous vous montrez là lé smic en
europe avec les taux les plus importants
mais c'est l'europe des vingt-sept à
landois que si on croit que six pays
membres de l'union européenne après il
ya tous les autres qui sont derrière ça
voudra dire qu'il faudra encore tirer
l'économie des autres au niveau de
l'union européenne je le rappelle il ya
que ça contributeur net c'est-à-dire des
pays qui verse plus que ce qu'il ne
reçoive et après il ya tous les autres
toutes les autres économies a tiré à la
traîne pour pouvoir essayer de faire
augmenter donc très court stage je vous
arrête parce qu'on a plus le temps
jouerait la réaction de monique baballe
là dessus
ils sont garants dire à tout le monde
les moyens de vivre dignement de son
travail est ce qu'il s'est passé ne
renie
pardon est ce qu'il faut une
harmonisation et un salaire minimum pour
tous en europe non parce que ça tire à
la france et à mesure que tout le monde
ait le même pouvoir d'achat et la même
capacité de vivre c'est là c'est moi je
veux bien qu'on tire toutes les
économies berlot moi je veux que tout le
monde puisse vivre correctement c'est
sympa
ça fait consensus ça fait consensus en
tout cas on verra quelles mesures seront
prises lors du prochain quinquennat et
avec qui merci beaucoup en tout cas de
nous avoir répondu et d' avoir débattu
ce matin en direct sur le plateau d' rt
france